people are always wondering why by
wearing gauge married well asked no more
because bindi Irwin is a married lady
I'm excited the 21 year old hit up
Instagram to announce that she and
Chandler Powell tied the knot on
Wednesday following their engagement
last July biggie shared the sweet pic
kissing her man after she said I do
wearing a long-sleeved lace gown her 23
year old groom and a more casual
button-up shirt and khakis you kind of
like my soul mate bindi caption the
puckered up shot in part quote I married
my best friend there are no words to
describe the amount of love and light in
my heart right now bindi added that
they've been planning their wedding for
almost a year and had to change
everything including slashing their
entire guest list due to the corona
virus pandemic a decision she said was
very difficult but more important to
keep everyone safe we wish all of our
friends and family could have been there
with us however it's lovely that we will
be able to share photos and videos but
on to the good stuff having the wedding
here in Australia that's that's what
means the most with my family bindi and
Chandler got married in the Australia
Zoo Gardens and she explained how her
family her mom teri brother robber and
her late dad Steve Irwin played a role
in her big day mum helped me get ready
Robert walked me down the aisle Chandler
became a husband and together we lit a
candle and dad's memory she said they
shared tears and smiles and love and not
even kovin 19 could stop them
quote thankfully since we all live at
Australia Zoo as a family we could be
there for each other it's nice because
every day is an adventure
bindis new hubby commented on his wife
he's pic writing the best day of my life
I love you so much the groom shared the
same pic on his Instagram alongside the
caption I married my best friend I'm
really grateful found you I think I
could be with anyone else in the wild
I'm Viviana Roberts hoop into his new
brother-in-law's comments writing I
couldn't be happier to welcome you into
our family and shared the same pic on
his Institue writing that it truly was
an emotional and beautifully spontaneous
day the most important thing is is
getting married here at Australia's age
because this is where I feel
- - ET spoke to the couple last summer
where bindi revealed why she and
Chandler decided to have their wedding
at the Australia Zoo I want to make sure
that my mom is there at but my brother
is there and that it's it's a really
close family event and that we remember
Dan so whether it's a clip that we play
of dad or something that just reminds us
of him and Ben he says she thinks her
dad who died in 2006 would have approved
of Chandler what do you think Dad would
have thought of that great guy oh I I
hope you'd like to I think he would I
mean Taylor's wonderful he's always up
for the challenge so I hope dad would
love Chandler and you know we all love
him I think he's great I think I think
your dad would have tested him yeah
morning noon and night and then approved
because your dad was kind of like that
dad always used to say if you're gonna
date a guy he has to crust the crock
pond fast like swim across the crockpot
and thankfully Chandler was a wakeboard
uh so you know what wakeboarding across
the crockpot I'm sure he would've passed
the test
[Music]
you